[Music]
this movie is called The Fault in Our
Stars so better start with a shot of a
bunch of stars you can find fault with
that I believe we have a choice in this
world narration about how to tell sad
stories on the one hand you can
sugarcoat it nothing is too messed up
that can't be fixed with an apology and
a Peter Gabriel song wait that's one way
to tell a sad story also is the movie
throwing shade that say anything cuz if
so few movie the cheesy romantic
comedies with easy resolutions you're
trying to take a shot at will all the
copycats that came out in the 30 years
since say anything made romantic
comedies awesome again okay get your
together guy who wrote this script
depressions not as that effective cancer
it's a side effect of dying no it's a
side effect of having a mental health
problem but whatever real truth movie
cute lon
also you paid money to watch this movie
care to read a book I wish I had that
cliche also hazel circled another
passage in this book and the fake author
has written six twos in a row it's
neither a sin that I see six uses of the
word two in a row or that I will never
be able to read this fake book to find
out why there are six in a row
damn you Van Houten support groups can
be a great way for you to connect with
people who are you might even see Tyler
Durden there we are gathered here today
literally Jesus movie thinks this cheesy
Christian is some kind of new comedic
territory we've never seen before I'll
spare you the gory details of Patrick's
ball cancer basically they found it in
his nuts okay so you told me it's spare
me the gory details then you go right
into the gory details what's wrong with
you woman and so I went not because I
wanted to or because I thought it would
help me damn it she's gonna narrate this
whole movie isn't she sorry wait
didn't we just see these assholes
playing brother and sister and divergent
if that's the case ooh
also did Hollywood only have like six
young actors to choose from and that's
why we got these two again in this movie
and while we got shailene woodley and
miles teller who was also in divergent
for the spectacular now do young people
want to act anymore it's the entire
talent pool getting diluted by the porn
industry
it's Gus using the stare at the girl
until she likes you technique because
let me tell you from experience that
never works I conducted many experiments
in high school and all I got was a
diploma I have great friends like
Augustus waters
Augustus waters this is a mad lib name
pick one Caesar and one of the four
major elements boom that's your cancer
friend named Len fierce
oh come on the movie wasn't that bad
good god that's the second time we've
seen this cliche also new lovers are
almost always faces oh she doesn't like
in the first and thinks he's a cocky
jerk that wouldn't be a movie otherwise
what there I thought we were in a church
basement but apparently we were
literally in the Heart Jesus sorry but
the dictionary no longer finds fault
with that particular use of 'literally
but you know what dictionaries wrong I'd
send the dictionary if I could but else
in the movie instead
wait what what's your name hazel hazel
and Augustus modern morose love story
takes its character names from times
ranging from olden to ancient enjoy
looking at beautiful people man this guy
does everything in the picking up chicks
how not manual really it's disgusting
you were doing really well too he was
there's always a Marsha isn't there
Marsha
it's a fatal flaw okay so do you
generally expect people to know that
word are you just an asshole also movie
unintentionally reminds me of the Brady
Bunch
huh Marsha Marsha Marsha they don't
actually hurt you unless you light him
this guy carries around a box of
cigarettes in order to espouse on life
philosophy so it's that type of movie is
it next thing I know I put myself in an
experimental trial and she went from
talking to him in the car to narrow
reading to the audience again just like
that how is someone miss comically bad
at driving even if they got a pity
license best layup award
what's her story damn Cutler t-shirt
Indiana University and Colts gear not
only is this guy from Indiana he routes
for everything from Indiana integrase
hmm I love it when you talk medical to
me so she went over to his house they
exchange book suggestions and then she
left I guess we also probably missed a
hilarious driving her back to her house
scene where he ran over five cats
iPhone is addicted expectations text
reading seventeen-year-old wearing a
Pink Floyd t-shirt
I'm confused Hollywood exactly what
generation are you trying to appeal to
with this movie welcome to the sweet
torture reading an imperial affliction
this asshole Gus calls us could be
girlfriend while his best friend is
having a psychotic episode over the
breakup with his girlfriend that's
killing two birds with one eye
I mean being an asshole to two people
with one phone call I wanted to call you
for a few days but I wanted to let you
wait and figure out if I'd ever call
again and I feel like ending your book
in the middle of sentence sort of
violates that contract no you just die
in life these two might as well be
discussing The Sopranos finale no one
who pants for a living takes notice of
the violent and loud teen angst outburst
taking place in their basement you know
what makes conversations about books and
movies great well nothing really but
especially when someone is breaking
stuff in the background for comedic
effect that's the thing about pain it's
a man's to be filled so she went over to
his house they exchanged book opinions
and then she left I guess we probably
also missed a hilarious driving her back
to her house scene where he crashed into
five McDonald's interrupted by a
hilarious Isak kills her reindeer
because he sad scene about this goddamn
book it seems like the big Isaac has a
psychotic episode over the loss of his
girlfriend scene could have been saved
for I don't know another movie perhaps
mainly because the first interaction
between hazel and Gus after days and
days of no contact was nearly worthless
and now here we are back to where we
started five minutes ago all this
awesome in this room is an orgy of
evidence that when you have teenage
cancer your parents spend out the ass to
keep you as happy as possible
iPod me cute with hands okay are we
really doing this perhaps okay will be
our always because the people who did
that are still happily together email
reading how would you like to go on a
picnic with me I know you girls love
this flick but I hope you realize the
script is basically paint-by-numbers
spontaneous weird guy with a dash of
cancer family that can't afford to send
their daughter damn stirrer damn as a
72 inch flat-screen TV in a
house Tom Hanks would be comfortable in
you are not right someone who doesn't
give a like him has been late a few
times
probably even accidentally and this is
18 year old dude one leg yeah because
there just aren't any girls out there
who would possibly have sex with a
one-legged dude I mean have you seen
Murderball those guys are quadriplegics
and they're getting laid sorry the
tomatoes are Mexican that's racist
so they went on a picnic he said they
were going to Amsterdam and then they
left I guess we probably also missed a
hilarious driving her back to her house
scene where he got laid five times but
it's so beautiful little insane oh it's
super insane this movie thinks it's
original but how many times have we seen
a girl fall in love with a guy or vice
versa simply because that guy is wacky
and does all sorts of unexpected or on
things that b'm use the girl like
insisting on always saying both are
first and middle names answer tons more
text reading symbols of lost childhood
cliche my hazel grace would be excellent
at cinemasins
all your efforts to keep me from your no
fail funny when I say that it's a
restraining order
this guy says it yes I'm a grenade you
can always date Steve Rogers I hear he
has no problem falling on grenades I
don't know I just I feel like it's my
responsibility to minimize the
casualties it's not you it's my cancer
cliche Craigslist folders name stuff
contain pornography ninety-five percent
of the time I'm just saying haha
pedophilia jokes always kill friends
friends this movie probably wouldn't be
two hours and 13 15 minutes long if some
of this insisting on being friends for
stupid reasons even though they love
each other was trimmed the
vault in our cheesy on screen text
messaging treatment Jesus half this
movie is rereading the book haha Google+
words every teen wants to hear from
their mother while naked in a towel
party in Amsterdam yo this girl is
crying at the prospect of meeting her
favorite author I need to write a book
author of the book this film is based on
who was known for vlogging with his
brother on YouTube now finds himself on
YouTube again being mocked by us good
god were dicks
you're gonna put this notion in this
little girl's nose come for the guy is
afraid of flying cliche American
Airlines if this movie is trying to
suggest the exterior shot of the plane
as an establishing one for the next
sleeping passengers one well then why
the is the plane flying at like
2,000 feet after having traveled over
Indiana Ohio Pennsylvania and New York
movie turns to all the guys that got
dragged to this movie and says haha cue
[Music]
falling in love soundtrack song montage
cliche movie that makes a big deal out
of going to Amsterdam has no interest in
showing you the real reasons for going
to Amsterdam
hey guys have I mentioned before what an
annoying character trait this is well
just in case I haven't up until now this
was all fun and games but now I actually
have a boner face if I was a teen and I
had terminal cancer and I was in
Amsterdam for the first and last time I
would not be going on a boat tour that's
all I'm saying movie suddenly turns into
the ending of Twilight she know what Dom
prignon said after he invented
champagne come quickly he said I'm
tasting the Stars yeah but did he find
fault with them that's my question I
mean not like a heaven where you ride in
a unicorn all day and live in a mansion
made of clouds but yes I definitely
believe in something everyone believes
in something you idiot and most people
who believe in God do not include the
unicorns in their belief system generic
dialog is generic if you admit that you
can play the accordion no one will hire
you in a rock and roll band
but apparently street bands need to of
you dust knocks out a spite before
entering without permission
[Music]
movies are better with current popular
hipster soundtrack songs as opposed to
any kind of Original Score loads of
alcohol and empty drinking glasses
everywhere or an orgy of evidence that
we're about to see some serious
alcoholism thank you so much for writing
back to yours are the first missives to
which I've replied but why you obviously
get tons of letters and emails and and
this is probably not the first time
someone wrote you saying I'm dying
please tell me the secrets to your book
so what gives just like her on purpose
since it's obviously the assistant that
actually cared about these two and not
Peter himself it's amazing that the
assistant didn't ask hazel and Gus to
come at a better time
or warn them about what an asshole this
dude is or anything other than running
them into this freight train of dick
headedness we bought them dinner last
night was our pleasure
long adored hero turns out to be asshole
cliche I thought meeting you would help
him but he could see that his work has
shaped real life apparently that was the
only part of your plan sure it made
sense in your head I guess but often
plans require preparation you basically
ambushed a writer who wanted to be left
alone and you lied to these kids about
the man Peter ITA's this is like a
double catfish perhaps we can do some
sightseeing we'll go with you anywhere a
person who lied to us Wow who knew
visiting the Anne Frank House was worth
possibly dying for um I'm glad you two
were finally kissing at all but this is
still the Anne Frank museum not 100%
appropriate yo teen love is worth a slow
clap also all these people clap because
I guess they know how long this took
they couldn't possibly just be horny
teenagers I mean this chick carries
around an oxygen tank look journey to
get to this kiss is implicit so they
went over to Anne Frank's house they
exchanged a kiss and then they left the
nice van houten secretary with no
further explanation I guess we also
probably missed a hilarious they get on
the subway scene where inexplicably Gus
has to drive the train and runs over
Willem Dafoe not Peter Van Houten but
Willem Dafoe tragic cancer sex also
pg-13 also why does her brother T to see
those boobs and we don't
oh this isn't divergent you say I should
know better who the is talking to
me right now okay ladies this sheet is a
sin we believe in equality here I mean
we don't want to see this dudes junk but
we know what sin when we see one we know
it's his first time but we're assuming
it's her first time too so I guess that
was the best sex ever right Lonnie my
chest what was this asshole smiling
about when he woke up this morning when
did he decide
oops time to tell hazel about my cancer
coming back this comes out of left field
it's a blindsiding that doesn't make any
sense because the dude has been nothing
but happy and unburden the whole time
he's been here until magically now
I should have told you everyone in this
movie dies well it'd be absolutely
ludicrous if we just made out right now
you mean without reminders of the
Holocaust cancer makes vandalism
acceptable and I'm okay with that
and I am NOT okay with that we also have
two dozen eggs so if if I were you I
would go back inside Monica's mom says
okay no need to call the police I guess
time to catch up on Catcher in the Rye
Holden Caulfield is such a scamp hi hi
9-1-1 question mark how many misdial
possibilities are there that you could
be unsure of who you call don't they
answer the phone 911 what is your
emergency Jesus you know you're not an
Amsterdam anymore I mean I know we all
live the dream that we're still in
Amsterdam once we get on that plane back
to the States but they can still arrest
you for underage drinking in public
wheelchair or not Gus told hazel to meet
him at the literal Heart of Jesus which
the movie is defined as the church
basement so how did she know to come to
the sanctuary what kind of a twisted
sick selfish son of a bitch would force
the two people he loves most to go
through this kind of Gus is the
devil man what would she have done if
she hadn't written a eulogy already this
asshole Gus called this pre funeral by
surprise what does she slack the
slightest bit on writing this thing
she'd wing it and he'd still love her
but deep down inside Gus would have
resented her until the day he died which
you know is tomorrow
Sunday's are simply bigger than other
infinities even when the villain of the
movie isn't there to hear those words
being thrown back at him it's still
annoying as I had something
prepared but now it's time to speak from
the heart cliche funerals I'd decided
are not for the table for the living
character states the obvious as though
it's some kind of insightful prose movie
tries to beat Manos the hands of fate
for longest driving scene ever no he
didn't write it Gus wrote it apparently
Gus wrote something down and then sent
it to Van Houten what why would he do
that I mean if he actually wanted the
odds to be good that she'd read it at
least we all wanted me remember
previously on The Fault in Our Stars
Lilly has the exact beginning and ending
of the series lost also hazel grace died
three weeks later followed by the blind
kid two days after who was hit by a car
John Green actually hold on
I think it's Hank green that's a sin
definitely hankering the one with the
glasses
I'll spare you the gory details of
Patrick's ball cancer
[Music]
I may switch you to zoloft
you know what why I'm here in the first
place
it's just sell you meth see this circle
time is a flat circle Gus I'm a grenade
[Music]
we're here with JC who wants to share
their story with the group what's your
name
hazel hey your mother's uglier than
hazel hazel really put your mother to
shame Harold was deep in thought for a
few brief moments from born Boulevard t
Cupid Avenue all the calculations and
all the rules and all the precision of
Harold's life just faded away its own
real story down the flat we'll have a
little feel for the rabbit rabbits and
now I get the tender ever